hi so I've come to brief you on some of
our recent developments of what we're
doing with treating television as data
and data treatments of television news
and political speech political
advertising and the like but I thought
I'd start off just in general with a
quick brief on the Internet Archive I'll
flip through a bunch of slides quickly
just to get everybody up to speed we are
a non-profit digital library dedicated
to universal access to all knowledge at
its heart we're an invitation to
collaborate that's why I'm here today we
are also really a series of beta tests
with a variety of different media to
beta test and demonstrate to society
that it's not that hard to approach this
dream of universal access to all
knowledge we're a non-profit we are
headquartered in San Francisco this is
our headquarters we bought a church to
kind of match our our logo it's a former
Christian Science church in that church
are 25 petabytes of unique data spinning
on servers that help keep the building
we host a variety of different media
including this many software titles at
million-plus books two million moving
images more than 2 million audio
recordings we have more than 3 million
hours of television within our archives
we only surface 44 public research US
television news but we're increasingly
whelping folks like you to virtual
server instances within which we call a
virtual library reading room to do
advanced data studies where we don't
have to release these enormous media
sets to the wild but yet they can inform
Public Interest applications lots of
ebooks and as we're known for through
the Wayback Machine more hundred more
than four hundred and thirty billion web
pages going back in time here's what CBS
the news look like in 1996 our digital
resources are utilized to on an
emergency basis sometimes when we
haven't been capturing things live we'll
get a calls we did from a international
group of investigative reporter saying
our our group and Crimea is in some kind
of danger if you could quickly grab our
stuff that'd be great we sent our
crawlers a work and just before our task
was finished their offices were invaded
we have you can reflect back on a
variety of different things and
sometimes there are highly transitory
post and this is an example of one that
where somebody seem to have taken claim
for downing a Ukrainian military
aircraft that looks like the same one
that turned out to be not in a military
but a civilian one websites come and go
our experience is a assessment of as of
two years ago is that the average
lifetime of a web page is a hundred days
this becomes very consequential in term
when these are used as reference points
here's a study done at Berkman Center
looking at the online web page
references within Supreme Court opinions
and found that fifty percent of them
were essentially dead they either went
nowhere or they a couple of them went to
a page where people have put ironically
hey this should have gone to this
webpage but it's no longer available get
a grip Supreme Court so we are
we think like George Santayana that
there are lessons to be learned that are
important for our future so too in the
domain of television the Library of
Congress was directed in the in the
1970s by Congress to preserve radio and
television it's a it's a big job it's
hard to do and they view really yet to
quite get going on it and starting in
the year 2000 we stepped in and said
well let's give it a hack other people
thought the same thing in the 1970s this
woman is a was an african-american civil
rights activist and librarian who in
1979 decided it was really important
that television news be preserved so she
started recording at home and 35 years
later 40,000 video cassettes later she
died and her family donated the archive
to the internet archive and that really
is the physical extent of all of that
which she recorded she did a good job
recording so we're looking to be able to
raise the funds sufficient to extend our
television archive which right now just
goes back to the year 2009 to be able to
digitize that which we have that goes
back to the year 2000 when we started
recording not only digitized but really
index research and then utilize
collections like Marion Stokes and
others to extend it further and further
back while we step forward everyday our
television news research library is now
available online at archive.org / TV
here's a simple interface we repurpose
the closed captioning to facilitate deep
search we think that highly granular
metadata of time coded media allows us
to facilitate data treatments as well as
human access and in fact kind of breaks
this ancient model we have of time-based
media video and audio being like an
ancient Egyptian scroll like if you've
got to get somewhere
and find something you just unfurl it if
we want to do it fast you and furl it
faster well we're trying to leap us all
into the post Gutenberg era where
there's indices you can use these
indices to search for anything will show
will bring you to the appropriate
portions which are search engine things
might be appropriate we allow you to
play it to embed it the URL is canonical
for that reference point here's an
example of an embedded quote someplace
our service has been used for initially
for summary research including by the
Berkman Center and MIT Media Lab and
this multimedia ecosystem study of the
twists and turns of the Trayvon Martin
story they've got good web colors like
we do to crawl new sites and political
blogs and for the first time they were
able to add television into this
assessment of how the approaches to the
various key characters and issues
twisted and turned and pivoted about
political points so one of the things
we're really interested in you know in
politics they're the most amount of
campaign spending is spending spent on
political ads and this year's we drawing
up to 2016 it's expected at least for
the presidential campaign it could be
the spending could be twice that of 2012
and most of that will go into television
advertising and television advertising
and political ads like all of television
just tends to sweep over us like a wave
front and there's very little pause and
rewind on the button in the case of
political ads these are made by masters
of persuasion and we think it would be
valuable for scholars and journalists
and others to be able to reflect
thoughtfully on the messaging and the
and maybe even inoculate folks not so
much on the message messaging but pull
out what are what are common tropes so
that when you hear the music go dark
or the contrast suddenly drop or the
appearance of children and light colors
that there may be a little subroutine
that we might be able to initiate to go
oh wait a minute wait a minute there's I
know this so we experimented last year
in the Philadelphia television market
area with the experimental collaboration
between a number of scholars and
journalists in this area there was a
number of key open congressional races
in which a lot of outside money started
to flow so we essentially captured the
the region's media ecosystem including
all of its television we were able to
identify all the political ads and join
them with information about how often
they played and other kinds of metadata
as well as outside information from
sunlight foundation and others on who
was behind who was behind who was behind
paying for the political ads there's a
number of research that's resulted from
this including this study that studied
well with with in television news how
much time was spent in television news
actually conveying substantive political
news not just horse races but something
that was a little bit more substantive
their threshold was kind of low as
compared to how much time they spent on
political advertising well unfortunately
the ratio was was pretty wide was for
every 45 minutes of political ads in the
television news in this region they got
a good one minute of subjective
political reporting when we think that
sort of might follow everybody's
assumption but here is an opportunity
for this to be quantifiable and not just
be quantifiable by somebody's claim that
hopefully maybe is trusted but for the
first time there is this television news
research library that anybody can go
back and reflect on that and make their
own counts and verify that hasn't been
possible before so coming up to 2016
we're having learned the lessons from
from
last year in Philadelphia we are
spreading out throughout key primary
States key regions and primary States
and going to be collecting all of TV
parsing the political ads joining the
political ads with those other metadata
and now this time around joining up with
professional journalists to to make a
digital library reference page for each
political ad that will have thoughtful
journalistic analysis of the content of
the ad as well as the larger context of
those issues raised in the ad within the
political campaigns itself these are our
launch partners to accomplish this at
scale we had to develop highly accurate
fingerprinting we use audio
fingerprinting and collaboration with a
scholar who's really the the developer
of this highly accurate audio
fingerprinting tool that allows us to
once we've identified one ad or frankly
anything else we can find all other
instances of it throughout our entire
library both that which we surface to
two individuals publicly the the news
portions of television and also all the
entertainment we did something
interesting in collaboration with color
v'let ro who's going to be speaking of
early just after me this is a
representation of the the primetime
debate of the most recent Fox News
debate showing you there's a complete
transcript and it shows you how much
each of these different elements of the
debate and who said it were featured
subsequently in television news program
so we took little sound bites and made
audio fingerprints of each and looked
over the ensuing week to across all the
television news that is all national
news and local news from select regions
to see when the where the ripple effects
went so this is the first time we're
just hacking this we're just
experimenting with this but this is a
kind of tool that's kind of like a
seismometer for
news to see the ripple effects of sound
bites you can use this tool it's
available now for instance here's a
excuse me here I've clicked on this
little element here here's Rand Paul
saying I don't trust President Obama
with our records it was quoted a hundred
and excerpted 167 times that is a
portion of that exact not somebody
saying this but actually Rand Paul
saying that's particular sound by here's
the incidence of it over time here's the
top five stations airing some portion of
that sound bite and down here and this
goes way down this way are all the
instances where that was quoted you can
click on any one of those all the
instances aware was coated up pops a
player and you'll see and hear that
portion it may not be the entire one
line it may be a portion of it this is
this fingerprinting tool resolves down
to about a second including significant
foreign language overdubbing which is
pretty cool oh pardon me so you see that
in this context and like with all the
rest of our library or all the embedded
material well if you click on this it'll
ill if you'd like it will take you back
to our library and to the context in
which that little sound bite was used or
any any one of our embedded library
reference pages or if there's a have
used one of our links as a reference
link it'll take you back and owing to
that that model I said we're trying to
break of the ancient Egyptian scroll
we're sort of presenting the entire span
of this of this program as kind of a
filmstrip model so you can click and
play here you can go here and listen to
what was just prior go here and listen
to what was just subsequent as well as
search within the program and conduct
your own research there this tool
also allows you to do faceted search
within that that collection of the of
the debate against a variety of things
including the stations the shows the
transcript you can do keyword trance
search for keywords and the transcript
as well as just do faceted search for
speaker here is all everybody all the
representations of candidates by all
networks for the whole speech so I'm
going to here is something i just
created last night because i thought it
was kind of cool here is the fraction
devoted to sound bites taken from the
debate in the subsequent week of us
television by the major networks and
you're able to to look here and see the
fraction within each network that they
devoted to each of the candidates that
is not the candidates but the actual
sound bites from each of those
candidates i just did this last night
the only things that popped out at me
right away so you look in the center
this is Fox News and you might kind of
whimsically note well maybe there is a
little bit of case for at least in this
instance of them being balanced I don't
know about fair but certainly balance
and then you look here at Al Jazeera
America and go whoa what is this that is
so smaller another one's well that's
Rand Paul and when you dive into the
debate you'll note that the rand paul
portions that most people carried and
that al jazeera america did in
particular were of surveillance and and
the like khalaf has also created a
really cool tool that's available to
track name mentions throughout this year
of every candidate you throughout
television news it's updated like all
our material we wait 24 hours we embargo
it before making it available in our
research library khaliv just published
this morning a
a blog post on archive blog that's blog
archive org describing a number of these
features that I just click through so
quickly so thank you very much for your
attention we think that were were the
threshold of really being able to make
breakthroughs in allowing and permitting
scaled digital access by machines by and
by people for the benefit of all we hope
you'll join us because as I said at its
heart we're an invitation to collaborate
so thank you very much